okay four people joining this livestream
we are looking at the resource framework
12 in language and final documentation
for it for version 12 and let's take a
look here documentation for resource
object yeah there's this one called
resource object new that is a overhaul
of this whole page that we started to
review in a previous visitor capital new
or locate all caps or just first cast n
ok so this goes to the list of resource
types what do we have there or do we not
have that for this version we don't well
we have a resource system guide page
which is also on the agenda for today ok
I don't know if we have something like a
dollar export formats for a list of
research tips no no that's not what we
would expect that we would expect a
guide page um right we have that that's
also an agent
ok um that link is probably not pointed
at the right location though ok let's
open that guide page resource system
okay hmm
did you make this page Bradley and I did
okay so what's this that's it will be no
repositories in archives resource system
page okay um do we have content for that
now
yeah it's just this five big tiles data
function no code do we have that
designed as they're designed for it
someplace I can send you a link to a
internal page that shows it okay then I
think that's what list of resource types
should go to so the list of resource
types we want to document the Wolfram
language functionality of the different
types so it would still be doc pages
well then okay what what does it go time
when you're filling in okay
that looks nice yeah so is this going
live soon yeah there'll be a search
field to that's the last thing we want
to get in place before we put her life
okay all right um and these okay so that
will just click over to the front page
there
oh gosh you start and fix this this nope
it's it's only q QA is testing in the
next update to resource system okay okay
so let's take a look at how it works for
import for example
ha ha it goes to that page which I
ignored
I thought that we've got a dollar import
formats no no it certainly shouldn't go
to that it needs to go to an organized
page like this um ok I think I'm
thinking that we should have a separate
page which lists the the actual
repositories that we have I want to try
writing that page ok so that page would
be called what's that why yes I think
that makes sense
okay so repositories and archives
actually we don't have we don't have any
archives yet so we should just say
wolfram repositories I think for now
well we can say repositories and
Archives whatever it won't make
somebody's life easier down the road we
want to include that did that have to
change your partial links ok so let's go
to the importing and exporting guide
page
you
you
you
that's weird they're in language
functionality related to archives
no not really not yet
um what are these that understand why
those show up
oh no they do shop at that okay fine
okay so then here we would say basically
you know there'll be sections here okay
um so I think
and that data repository thing should be
an external link I don't know quite how
to do that okay to the actual data
repository front page makes sense share
the little DMA at the end that's not how
it no no I'm not that's not what I'm
saying
look I'm saying you link it to a raw URL
okay I can actually do this here
I can just say link to URL and it'll say
the URL
contacts okay this is not the right
thing for me to be doing what is the URL
of the data data repository HTTP colon
backslash backslash slash slash forward
slash slash a repository dad well from
cloud.com
okay
resource data default data for from a
data repository entry is that right yes
um now then this is what else is there
that's just resource object for the data
repository right right
so um full uh well uh representation of
the posture entry yes um it's really a
handle yes
that's what it really is isn't it guests
okay now is there anything else that we
want to mention here okay so this is um
the typical things that happen there are
data set and or yeah um there's a data
repository guide page oh for goodness
sake what's that there's a data
repository guide page that mentions a
lot of these things as well if you
wanted to pull from there well but then
then no this doesn't make sense
oh for goodness sake
why are we doing this page then we don't
need this page I said this pages can be
a listing of what saves but then why
don't we just go
the page of lists the websites I mean
this is okay so we need a corresponding
page for the function repository do we
have one for the new repository no
there's a neural networks guide page
that's probably 70% of relapse so I
don't think we need it another one but
we have one for a function of ester well
I mean I'm sorry why is that grayed out
there no that's going to the wrong place
that's going to that's going to
interpret us so that's an incorrect link
there okay
both of those are incorrect yep make a
note fix it yep okay so so I'm sorry
let's unscramble this a bit so we're
gonna need a page for function
repository that is parallel to this page
correct yes we we've made that we
reviewed it in a knitting meeting I
don't know two weeks ago okay so let's
look at that okay fine okay
so how do you get to this page from the
webpage that you were showing me earlier
from this page from here how do you get
to that guide page yeah I never like
this we need a link to documentation it
should say Wolfram language
documentation underneath here and don't
we have that for the data repository
already we do there's a using the data
repository link that goes to a reference
we can do something similar okay well
what the heck's that doing that's going
to that blog post why we can revisit
that bar we haven't looked at in a
little bit we can that doesn't make
sense you could you oughta have a
separate page for submitting that's a
workflow for submitting to the data
repository right yeah I think we have
one so we can just change that link gosh
does anybody
to this page whether this have why
doesn't this have a contact me thing
each of those is a contact form okay
I'll check with the groups that receive
that information I don't think we've
seen a lot of traffic on there it's due
for a review okay / doesn't help these
things are in a ghostly blue color makes
them know exactly pop out as being
important um okay so why in the case of
the function repository look at the
neural net repository okay so this needs
documentation just needs a link to
documentation
and arguably the function repository
could look the same way okay make sense
though the function repository is going
to need something about how you submit
to it that probably will link to a
workflow here so--but you know something
like um documentation I wouldn't say
well from language documentation because
that will be confusing because the whole
thing um just like we could say it's a
repository documentation here so there
again what
just like the data repository says using
the Wolfram data repository we can have
the same title fine
and that we could have submitting too
often function repository same thing
that we had for data yeah I don't think
this is necessary there because it's
like you don't say it's a bunch of
Wolfram language functions yeah pretty
pretty straightforward yeah we can look
at adding those to the landing page
um okay let me ask you this did you get
the source code link here not yet that
should also be in our next update when
is the next update did we say we should
end it next week
yeah by next week yeah okay okay all
right so what are we concluding about
this page we don't need it right it's
just gonna go to the listing is just
gonna go to that webpage so we we need I
think either this or a resource system
kind of top-level guide page right which
is the other one that we were looking at
right yeah but I mean that that can be
gone that is not the listing that we're
listening from resource object new
should go to the webpage so from there
I'd like to have similar to import
export formats a page for each type of
resource object that identifies the you
know common metadata to that type oh yes
that's that's worthwhile thing and and
so the the directory of those pages
would be where that link goes well this
link here goes yeah
so if we have a repository as an
archives page or resource system page
that lists the different types wherever
we list those those type pages is what
we want that link to be
okay but but we don't have those type
pages yet
not just yet no we were gonna abduct
those shortly post 12 was the last part
of it so what are we gonna do right now
I mean right now we're gonna list those
things on this page on right we got to
list them on this page because we've got
to make lists of what the available
metadata is might make sense sure well I
think so I mean other words what are we
gonna do okay so let's look at this page
then and and I don't have to go back and
look at the original resource object
page right that that this page is
searched
okay tell me the full metadata spec it's
nice to give people but they don't
necessarily need it to create these
things because we have the definition
notebooks okay well how do P
for the definition notebooks so that's
what on the page that you had about
[Music]
smashing that what this should do is
this should have a thing here that says
for right now
it seems to me well yeah that's not
really right it's not really right okay
I mean this page will be a very very
sparse guide page right now right mm-hmm
I mean it could link to one of the other
ones the other guide page that is behind
Wolfram repositories and archives on
your desktop and then we would add when
we make them we would add links to the
different resource types this is not
useful right using resources here this
is not useful that's that's wrong okay
so
okay um
Ethan our livestream is saying we'll be
nice people to be able to feature
request and vote for new datasets or
functions to little posit or ease
actually even better how about people
just contribute those datasets or
functions that's the idea
there that's what we would like to see
that's kind of why we're building it in
this way um okay so so let's do this
page okay so let's say this becomes
Wolfram data repository um see the thing
is this isn't just our data repository
right um
[Music]
we say resource types and then have data
and neural net and no we can't we don't
do that we can't we don't have a second
level thing here so I'm saying right at
the top a very brief one level thing
that's just going to about data
resources function resources neuron that
resources okay then what we do is we say
here um I don't know how you did that
for this thing here let me try that
again for this um I don't know how this
works exactly but that um
something like that then we say resource
data which only works for data resources
right no it works on net battles it
works on their lives yeah
what does it do in that case same thing
is never okay let's not document that we
don't need to you okay
resource data um okay so good net model
always pulls the primary model right but
now net model takes it takes okay okay
so then that's resource data okay penny
we should have a link to that wall from
data repository guide page here too
right well then let's link it from here
yep
what does it call Wilton data repository
data repository is it called V or just
welcomed better a person just waffle
Nader of a story okay
no that's not correct it's it's a it's a
framework for setting up repositories
and archives um it's a framework for
distributing Wolfram language content
with metadata
the system is can be used both both for
private content used for private content
the system is the is the is the basis
for how the Wolfram data repository
variety okay how about four we can link
for a variety of Wolfram hosted
repositories and archives or from
curated repositories and archives it can
also be used for private repositories in
archives okay
deployed entries and repositories and
archives get a webpage giving
information we've got a web page that
typically gives it gives documentation
and examples
something like that yeah Ethan from our
livestream says it'd be nice to back
these with github repositories yeah yes
yes yes yes yes although I I don't know
what's quite involved in that and how
get linked relates to that do you
understand that but we've had some
conversations about that it's certainly
something we've got our eye on but
haven't you know rolled our sleeves up
yeah should look at it okay okay so here
we've got what is it called resources
towel from cloud tom / function
repository you know what we should make
um this one be that same it'll it works
but every document is linked that we
have on any announcement or blog post or
anything goes to the data repository one
and if using this one you might actually
click a link and end up back at the data
repository subdomain who cuz I'm just
trying to be consistent here
okay now this wants to be reference a
function from a function resource okay
and that's going to link to the function
repository page
okay now known that resources ok what's
the URL where the same okay and here we
need to say net model and then we're
going to say just from a neuron that
resource right yes actually maybe this
is better symbolic representation or
resource function does that is that
better no I don't think so okay
I hear I wouldn't say reference I would
say get import okay
okay so now we need to say um okay so
now um okay
you
um accessing resources
okay and that needs to link to you say
that leads to link to the neuron that's
page
correct yes
you
you
okay all right fine so that becomes the
link then for list of resource types so
this by the way becomes a non futurist
page
you
okay
so now here is this all new stuff down
here the example see I think I've read
it all the examples actually they're all
new since 11 3 I copied them in to exist
ok let's exercise this page this is not
happening
ok ok now this page is this page
referenced from where is that page
reference from on the main guide page
that's something we need to figure out
yes by the way there's a complaint on
the live stream that resource function
of blob of r comma quotes definition is
ugly
oh well there's a new resource function
that is will be published eminently that
will make that a much better interface
for that ok so context we have these
internal contexts in their ugly we know
it and we're making a better tool okay
so this is resource object and I'm
trying to figure out how to come how to
not mess things up and yet copy over
this one so you tell me that I can just
delete all of this stuff and copy over
is that correct yes ok up to you alright
let's go down here copy ok
it's all version
trol worst thing that can happen is
shush Brian and I figure out how to do
it properly I think it worked unless you
edited the meditator up there I think
that worked I did not okay let's
exercise that page okay okay so this now
that link works I was that link work
it's probably not pointing anywhere I
was few tries cuz that patient exists
yet okay let's do few tries that oh wow
it's got some funky error message there
but that list of resource types okay so
where are we going to link to what you
think of as
what earth is that doing going to the
interpreter that's just completely crazy
we've got or not to fix that I'll just
fix it right now what the heck did it do
you
you
you
it seemed to work okay
okay now how do we get the metadata how
do we specify the metadata you think you
need a whole page to do that and if so
where is it going to be linked from I
think a whole page would be good trying
to I mean it's possible with just three
types we could do it on this resource
system page but you know as we grow
it'll be no no I understand that I
understand that but I mean the do you
want okay but notice that data resources
links to the data repository page okay
mm-hmm
so there's no possibility then of it
linking to see your thing we should just
describe the metadata on the data
repository page well I'm not sure that's
right but how much metadata is that
eight to twelve properties all right
let's see an example of one of those
okay so
okay wait a minute what is all this
stuff here all right the other page so
so remember please that we still haven't
linked we haven't knitted this Wolfram
resource system um we still need find it
at home on the top level page
I think for now that resource object is
the place where we should list what the
metadata is and we may later change that
okay makes sense because we don't have a
good place on these guide pages to list
this metadata it's just a bunch of
strings in the Association
I mean alternatively okay this list I
don't see how to do this well oh yes I
do
yes I do yes I do yes I do um yes I do
here's how we do this um okay what's the
type here it's called data yes see
that's what we do
and that becomes a link to this to this
new page yeah what I'm saying resource
type for data with with standard fields
what should we say define supporting
supporting stand no it would you say
supporting standard collection of field
standard a size that you're describing
where the link was going no no not at
all
[Music]
supporting
for for content and metadata so what I'm
suggesting
what future eyes that for now but that's
where it should link I think um do you
want a resource type to be camelcase
since it is the key and a metadata field
of resource object Wow
no absolutely not okay so then we'll go
down there function etc terror terror
and then these will be links which will
be in some funky color phrase supporting
fields of them yeah I know I mean it's
gonna be kind of boring but it'll say
this down here um it's a little
different yeah okay so
you're on that's what is it called what
what's the name neural net neuron that's
supporting evaluation and training
training including evaluation training
etc something like that something like
that okay okay let's go back over here
to the resource object and what do we
need a document here so every resource
has a resource type right yes
um have those share the following
standard metadata properties okay fine
so that's all that's correct for all of
these right that's right okay
um the setting the value possible values
for resource type as well standard
values for resource type include
okay this is where we get to say data
um
action to be applied to arguments known
that allowing evaluation training
something like this okay um possible
start values for resource type include
hum okay
for resource and public source metadata
Association is keys
boy I wish this weren't so long did we
copy these directly from Dublin source
Dublin descriptions yeah why isn't there
a title well let's this is pretty silly
if I might say so
okay so what we need here and we
certainly should start off with title oh
I see this is the title for the source
where's the title name of the resource
oh boy if this is the verbatim Dublin
core specification we might as well just
leave it here
I can't recall it's been a while I can
look up Doug lecour real quick okay
you
you
you
you
actually here um cause like we changed
it a bit
creator instead of person organization
or group they just say entity but let's
say data
you
this is the main point here right yeah
how its integrated to the language
okay so in principle those might become
links to something else in the future
okay and presumably we're gonna have you
know many more of these fairly soon
right including things like the system
model you know stuff and so on okay now
you have special things for different
okay so now you have
um you have special metadata for the
data cases that correct
each resource type has its own
extensions that net neural net
extensions are actually almost the same
as data they use pretty much the same
values sorry say that again what each
one has its own extensions neural nets
happened to be where the list of
extensions I don't have it ready if you
look at the 11:3 version of this stock
page you can see it for data yeah I
thought we were we don't have anymore we
don't have the 11:3 version I was blown
away you just told me to blow that away
so I blew it away well if you have an
11-3 installed or something on I
probably can just look at it in the 12
here because it said some right the
built page so like in the middle of
Canton elements content size content
type default content
categories so I'm sorry I'm confused
here this is only relevant for Daytona
or what it's also relevant for neural
nets because they use the same tools but
it's not no no that stuff's it's nurse's
content means anything for function
resources what did you change here you
changed a bunch of stuff took out
everything that was not general to all
repositories okay so where did you put
it back in again like content size I
have it in a notebook somewhere that I
couldn't try to dig up it might take me
a while I think it's on my old laptop I
thought I don't understand what you're
talking about I mean the the plan was
told me yeah yeah we had a meeting where
we wanted to do this and I had we had
all that content ready for you and you
said we can do these this make these
notebooks after 12 so I thought that was
not gonna be this meeting so I do not
have this content okay so get we need to
get it ready cuz this page is now got
much stuff that's been removed from it I
don't even understand the C also appears
to be new here right you just added that
yes yeah it's a standard property that's
been added since okay you took out
categories categories is not like
neural-net calls them task types they
have a different name for how they sort
things okay Bob I've found that notebook
just send it to me then it was it is
still pretty rough it's not something we
can copy/paste into place no I
understand but
okay it's Santa
or there's all sorts of stuff that we
thought would be on these type specific
pages well we can make the type specific
pages but for right now we have to put
something yeah okay
this was our outline to Docs so they
know or are you suggesting we just don't
document this for 12 Oh what are you
suggesting if I can turn it around real
quick that would be good hmm otherwise
why don't we simply do this why don't we
put in here we put a section heading how
do you put a section heading above these
I don't even know but Raja has section
headings and in things
I don't know how you put a section
heading in here okay but let's imagine
you put a section heading here and you
say data resources and then you list
these things just there okay
but I agree that this stuff for example
I don't even know what to get
well isn't that listed here and what
does data set do anyway if the resource
if the data is a data set its gets it if
you just say data set of a resource in a
resource object
yeah it's it's no different than
resource data it's just just convenience
well if it's an entity store then it'll
give an appropriate error message in not
give a result okay what is the get doing
say miss resource state there are there
all I think we shouldn't bother to
document those right that's why they're
not there yeah okay okay so what I think
we should do here is we should have
sections here and we should simply
document okay so let me write this for
example um let's say I'm going to write
this with some fake thing because I
don't know what the M okay so that's a
fake get what I'm saying
yeah right um okay so now this will then
say
is this so you can use those if you're
defining a resource programmatically you
can use things one way and then they'll
be but if you're retrieving it from the
repository or
a cloud object or something they'll be
canonicalized into what I'm calling just
run what you said I'm sorry so so the
ones I'm kind prescriptive are ones that
you would use when you're
programmatically defining a resource
okay so we say typical elements in a
data resource include and now we can say
Ana retrieved data resource include um
typical elements oops I think I just did
this wrong um typical elements used in
constructing a data resource include
that right that's right okay and there's
that um okay typical elements used in
organizing data resources in a
repository include right correct yep and
that gets us everything here yes
typical additional elements okay so here
now this is descriptive so content
elements is that right yes
names of elements in the resource right
where the content of the resource can be
from where can be stored okay this is of
the default element now it's backwards
to default
right yep okay all right that's those
okay
so content element locations is that
whether all the content is or is that
where the default content is content
element locations is association where
the keys are element names and the
values are cloud objects or local
objects okay but then what's content
okay content location is a directory
basically that is where the local cache
is or where the resources in the
repository so to me it could probably
better be named resource location but
it's something nobody ever really has to
interact with then why are we even
mentioning we can we can leave it out I
was I was being probably complete but if
you look at the metadata you'll see it
but there's no there's no real reason
interact with it okay let's leave it out
okay then content element locations do
we need to people need that yes
definitely
what is it it's an association so in
saying where each element is located
what do you mean by located a cloud
object a local object of an extra end
content locations of elements given us
an association
um I think that's enough okay now what
if a fault that's important it's a
problem right there name of the default
element as retrieved by resource data
right
you
that's storage locations of elements
right yes
okay used in constructing what's that
intent or a content well if you want to
create a resource with just one element
you can just use contact well what's
what the content elements doing here and
what's the two versions of content
elements doing here right so content
elements when you're describing it will
take in memory content so it's not
pointing at a storage location no the
content elements I thought just
retrieved a bunch of strings right bit
gets canonicalize to that right right
that's why there's this difference
between different names what is content
content is an alternative to most
content element locations antonella
focus is a simplest dummy case when you
just have one element and you just want
it to be named automatic you just say
content goes to expression it's this
easiest way to get started but it's not
what you want to use if you're doing
sophisticated resources
stand calling concept elements the same
here I would have thought that was
content element values yeah that would
make sense it's I mean we I don't doubt
you men therefore 12 it's not gonna work
well then that's future or is it okay it
sounds good um
I mean surely you can change that name
maybe not I don't understand what
content element functions are they're
predefined functions that apply to other
elements in the resource so we have like
in the data repository we have I created
all those text resources the plain text
is the default content but if you want
to get the paragraphs instead of storing
it and duplicate we have a Content
element function that's breaks as
various write functions to generate
derived elements from content to derive
elements from content to derive
additional elements okay um okay all
right so then we're gonna need the same
thing so why don't you mock this up and
then let's yeah let's do what yeah let's
do one more iteration on this and I
think this will be fine for twelve okay
and and you was there another page I
really gotta go to a different meeting
but was there another page that I mean I
thought resource function okay
we've looked at already good okay fine
well surely you can use a simpler
function the nest did look up on some
giant Flintstones creature we can we can
find a simpler example at first like the
grey code example yeah yeah we can we
can find we can put a simple first row
yeah let's avoid the Paleolithic
references you know yeah we'll put that
one down in the mid down lower fair
enough
okay I'll push all this stuff thank you
all good all right so and I just I'm
really looking forward to so you have
started the content generation engine
for the function repose
is that right yes we've many hours so
last week or so how's it going it's
moving along yeah I think probably 60%
of the speed I would have hoped but not
not 5% so that's fine okay okay good all
right well let me know when you need to
meet with me about that stuff about the
content generation okay yeah okay sounds
good
all right thanks so really thanks to
people on the live stream